welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for our presentation
titled introduction to image processing
for high content screening
it is my pleasure to introduce to you dr
mark bray dr bray is a data scientist
novartis institutes for biomedical
research
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them
at the q a box our speaker will address
your questions following at the end of
the presentation please
join me in welcoming dr mark mark bray
i will now turn the presentation over to
him
so welcome everyone to this educational
program from
sbi 2. so i will be walking you through
as
an intro to high content screening high
content analysis image and data analysis
um my name is mark bray i'm a data
scientist
from uh niver the navarre institute of
biomedical research
and it's my pleasure to be presenting in
front of you today
so just as a broad overview what i'll be
presenting is actually part of a
kind of a larger toolkit to build up any
sort of high content screening lab
you need a whole host of basic skills
including biology fluorescence
microscopy instrumentation
informatics and data analysis so
everything i'm going to be presenting
to you is much is part of a much larger
set
of other skills as well and in
particular
um i'll divide this into three buckets
there's the um asset development part
which of course is
the one of the most important parts of
any hcs
lab and then there's a hardware and
image acquisition
and assuming that you have both those
things in place
then the image and data analysis comes
later but
the success of any sort of image and
data analysis campaign
hinges on having the first two pieces
put together
in a in a fairly tight way so as far as
an outline goes i'll be
walking you through these following
subcategories
the image is quantitative data then i'll
walk you through
how to identify the foreground of image
once you have the foreground identified
and identify objects you'll be splitting
them into clusters
once you have clusters then there are
the cellular sub-compartments
to be identified and once you have those
you can start extracting measurements
and then
i'll cover a little bit of statistical
analysis beyond that
so first the image has quantitative data
so i'm assuming that if you're here
listening to this presentation you don't
necessarily need to be told
but images contain a a very
rich wealth of information we're at the
point now where we can
collect amazing fluorescent images from
single cells such as that shown on the
left all the way up to even whole
organisms such as um the c elegans worms
shown
on on the right
so as far as taking these images and
then extracting all the information that
we possibly can out of them
uh we can subdivide that into a series
of steps the first is um
acquiring the image of course so that
necessitates that you have your hardware
set up um accordingly then there's
some degree of pre-processing that's
usually done to the images in order to
set yourself up for success
once you have that then you can get into
detecting the individual objects within
the image
through segmentation and this also
includes say
3d assays and time lapse imaging and
tracking as well
making measurements and extracting
features once you have that done
and then object classification
interpretation and any recognition is
kind of the end game
of this of a high content screening
campaign
and then the results as as as a final as
a final feature
so for image analysis um there's a whole
host of various software solutions you
can of course
use and i've divided them up into two
basic categories they're not necessarily
mutually exclusive
but i find it helpful to think of them
in these in these terms
the first is application modules so
these are good for someone who's new to
high content screening or just
kind of needs something more off the
shelf that just works
these are usually put together by
microscope vendors they come packaged
with the microscope itself
and they usually feature become a very
good user interface they're usually
quite quick
they also come with kind of a suite of
validated standard assays
and the approach is that these
standardized solutions usually have or
is somewhat can't um you don't
necessarily need to be an expert
or know even know that much about an
image analysis to make this work
you can essentially just um take it a la
carte
plug it in and go however these sort of
solutions while they're very simple may
um
not be quite adequate for more complex
um high content
uh image analysis solutions which is
where the second category comes in
um which what i've called here as a
development environment
uh these are good for creating new
assays um with
and they usually entail a more flexible
approach you have a more customizable
assay design
instead of something that's off the
shelf um oftentimes not all the time but
often times
various modules or sub
subsets of workflows can be combined
into one overarching workflow
the downside if you want to call it that
is that there is a higher cost of entry
you do usually need to understand some
degree of image analysis
in order to make this work um say a
programming language or some basic
scripting or something of that nature
and of course many solutions kind of
some can do both of these or
kind of span the range between these two
extremes
so here i have some um examples
of software solutions and i emphasize
that this is not
comprehensive so on the commercial side
you have acapella by perkin elmer
definions
molecular devices ge so basically all
the big names in the microscopy
um in the microsp domain usually have
some amount of software that can
that can be used for this purpose aside
from those you also have matlab
photoshop
and other packages which can also be
used for very basic
for basic image analysis on the other
side
there's open source software which is
put out by the
imaging uh public community um
imagej and fiji are our well-known
solutions cell profiler is another one
now there's bioimage ic bob 3d
essentially the sky's the limit usually
a google search will give you any any
one of these
so this is just kind of a broad overview
and again not comprehensive
but you have a wealth of solutions
that are at your disposal just a matter
of picking the right one for your
particular application
so assuming that you've picked a
software that is um to your liking then
you can get into actually
identifying or working with an image
itself
so the first part is identifying the
image foreground
so here i'll just call this calls um
object identification and you it's
this is known by anyone of a number of
names but a name that's
a term that's very often used in this
domain is called segmentation
and all segmentation is just simply
taking image and cutting it up or
partitioning it into regions of interest
and i divide this procedure into
a couple of basic parts and the first
part is distinguishing the foreground
from the background by thresholding now
here we define the foreground as the
pixels or the individual units of an
image
that are of interest so the foreground
are the pixels that you care about
and you're trying to distinguish those
from the background which are the pixels
that you don't care about
and since we're dealing with fluorescent
images
usually the foreground are the pixels
that are much brighter than the
background
and so you want to pick a threshold
which divides up the foreground from the
background by virtue of some fluorescent
intensity
now in order to set yourself up in order
to detect the foreground
well sometimes not all the time but
usually
there's some amount of elimination
correction that might need to be done
just by virtue of the fact that you're
using a microscope
the optics themselves will introduce
non-uniformities into
your image regardless of what the
obstacles of whatever the biological
sample may actually
be so for example in this image this is
a set of
tiles of a specimen that are tiled
together and hopefully you can see
that going from left to right the left
side of each tile is slightly brighter
than
the right side and so if you're looking
to
try to identify the biological sample in
the middle
and you're trying to do this by
thresholding to get your um your
foreground pixels
if you sit were to pick one particular
value of the threshold
it might be biased towards the brighter
pixels on one side
versus the darker pixels on the other
side so
by correcting for the illumination you
can even out
this gradient of illumination and such
that a single
threshold might actually work
so one simple example of fill emission
correction
is shown here where we have a single
well from a multi-well plate
with some c elegans worms in that well
and you can see very clearly here that
the center of the well is much brighter
than the corners
one way to do lumination corruption is
is essentially flat fielding you
approximate the background
which in this case is being done by
averaging many
images from many wells together to
estimate what that background
fluorescence is
and then you can either subtract off or
divide
by this approximation of the background
to get your final image
and you can clearly see that the
background is now
very um homogeneous and now you have a
much better chance of picking out these
worms
from from the swell
um one way this can also be done is um
through a technique
called uh top hat filtering or rolling
ball filtering for
essentially as seen in this image again
you have a
gradient of intensity from left to right
on the
left hand side of of the image and then
what you're essentially doing is taking
um this essentially this ball
and rolling under the profile which you
see at the bot at the bottom left
to approximate again approximate the
background and then subtract that off
in order to yield a uniform background
for which you could identify the
features
in this case these dark spots much more
much more accurately um on the right on
the right hand image than the one on the
left
okay so that's as a pre-processing step
so assuming that you've managed to
sufficiently correct the background of
your images
now you're ready to actually do the
thresholding and so
again the idea of thresholding is shown
in a very simple schematic here
let's say what you're seeing here is a
histogram of pixel intensities the pixel
intensities are
shown on the x-axis darkest pixels are
on the left
brighter pixels are on the right and the
number of pixels
at each intensity is shown by the height
of the histogram
and so the foreground is that small peak
that's over on the right and you want to
distinguish this peak from the
background pixels that are over on the
left so the question here
is what is the best threshold value or
single value
that would divide the distribution on
the left um the pixels you don't care
about from the distribution on the right
the pixels that you do care about
so there are any wonderful number of
places where you could place a threshold
for example
so if you placed it here towards
uh the left you can see here from this
image
from this little tile we're showing a
fluorescent nuclei
on the dark background and the green
line
shows or encloses all the pixels that
are above that chosen threshold
and you can see here that yes this green
outline
does um surround or enclose the nuclei
but it gets a little bit more than you
bargained for some of the background the
dark background is also captured
by this choice of threshold so in this
case the threshold is captured a little
too much
let's say we put the threshold more to
the right closer towards
the brighter pixels so here again the
green
line shows what's been what's enclosed
by this choice of threshold
and you can see that um yes we've been
captured only the pixels that are within
the nucleus
but only the brightest pixels um the um
you can see some of the
um nuclear pixels peeking out
outside of this green of this green
outline so in this case
the choice of threshold was a little too
stringent for capturing too much
so it's a kind of a classic goldilocks
problem in which the
um optimal choice of threshold of course
is somewhere in the middle where you're
getting just
much um not too much not too little but
you're capturing something just right
you're just getting just the pixels that
belong to the nucleus and nothing else
so this is kind of a trivial example
where the histogram
very clearly shows you what the right
answer would be
but in reality things are often much
more complicated than this
um but there are cases in which a um
you know due to the biology or due to
the assay
um finding a single value that divides
foreground from background
may actually not be doable so in those
cases um
one technique that's becoming more and
more popular are um
pixel-based classification in which
there are certain software packages in
which you feed in the images you
then annotate by hand to create a
training set
or a training set of pixels to say that
these pixels on the image belong to the
foreground
these other pixels in the image belong
to the background
and maybe other pixels belong to some
other class entirely and then
you're basically letting a machine
learning algorithm on the back end
figure out what are the distinction
characteristics of the foreground
versus background versus whatever class
and then the computer comes up with the
final with the final answer
so this can also be very powerful and is
becoming more and more uh
you'll see techniques like this in more
and more use uh nowadays
okay so through whatever method whether
it's by thresholding or by machine
learning
assuming that you've now identified the
foreground now you can start identifying
individual objects within this
foreground region
so um thresholding is fine and good of
course
and if your objects within the image
are very well isolated then you're
basically done
each foreground region constitutes an
individual object or
and by object i mean a collection of
touching pixels
that constitute a single biological
entity
um of course in many cases like say
nuclei
you have um nuclei that are touching
for example so here we have two objects
that are touching each other and so you
would have
one foreground object but multiple
um uh multiple objects within this one
foreground region
so the next thing that you need to do is
identify the individual objects that are
contained within this foreground blob
so again there are different ways to do
this
one example that you'll see is something
called watershed
segmentation in which you can consider
the image as a surface for basins
here you're essentially looking at it as
if it were a
set of trenches in which you are putting
a pipe underneath and then pumping up
water to fill the basins from underneath
the areas
or the regions where one basin begins to
overflow into its neighbor
when that happens that constitutes an
edge between basins
and so water shedding now is a very
common common technique
you may or may not see it referred to by
this name
but i just wanted to familiarize you
with this particular term
other ways to separate touching objects
so this intensity based method
or water shedding as i described it
often works best
if the objects in question are brighter
at the center
and dimmer at the edges so for example
for nuclei for example
that often fits the bill in which
because the uh
say dappy or hosting nuclei usually are
pretty bright towards
center and so you can rely on a
dim edge between touching nuclei in
order to identify
regions or the lines that separate one
nucleus from another another technique
is a shape based
technique which works can work pretty
well
for touching identifying touching
objects especially um
if the intensity is rather is more
homogeneous
in other words if all the intensity is
so bright that you can't necessarily
distinguish
one object from its uh from its neighbor
in this case you're leveraging the fact
that for some objects
nuclei be a good example where um
the areas where the nuclei are touching
um usually have some sort of indentation
or a convexity
or i should say concavity between them
and then you can use
those indentations as a key that's the
um there are two touching there are two
objects that are touching
at that spot
okay so assuming that you've
segmented or de-clumped these clusters
and to identify the individual objects
within your foreground regions now you
can start identifying the cellular
compartments themselves
so the first thing um or the first
compartment that is very commonly
identified is the
um is nuclei nuclei stains are very easy
they're very cheap
and simple to do so i usually recommend
that
you try to identify the nuclei first and
if you don't have a nuclei stain
i highly recommend that you actually go
get one um because they will
set you up well for identifying other
objects within within your image as well
so identify nuclei is easy identify
identifying cells though that can be a
different matter
regardless of the cell stain that you
use just the fact that the cell stains
are usually more
direct by virtue of the cells themselves
being heterogeneous
the contrast is often just a little bit
lower and especially
in confluent monolayers you may have
cells that are very readily touching
each other and it becomes even unclear
even by eye
in this image i'm showing you here as to
where one cell ends and where the other
begins
so the techniques that the techniques
that i just mentioned
in terms of thresholding can be very
straightforward for nuclei
not so much for for cells as you can see
by the segmentation results on the
lower right where the outlines of this
of
these segmented objects don't really
follow the outlines of the cells
so another way to tackle this is
something that
can be called secondary object
identification and again if you're using
um
say vendor software this may come under
a completely different name but the
principles ascent is the same
um this the workflow basically is to
identify the nuclei first
in leveraging the fact that they're high
contrast they're readily identifiable
and then using a cell stain
you use their nuclear objects that you
just identified
and grow outward from those objects
using
the cell stain as a guide in order to
tell it where the growth to start and
then the growing outward pixel by pixel
continues until you hit
um a neighboring growing area
so that is a way to identify cells
without having to
necessarily threshold in the regular way
now for some assays you don't even need
to necessarily identify the cell body
itself
so for example for a translocation assay
you just need to know
is my protein or marker of interest in
the nucleus
or in the cytoplasm you don't even
necessarily need to
exactly define the borders of the
cytoplasm in order to make that
determination
so in that in that case you may not even
necessarily need a cell stain
you could just simply take the nucleus
and grow it outward by some number of
pixels to
essentially approximate the cytoplasm
and then go from there so that allows
you to
go down not have to use even a cell
stain reagent
and get the same basic result just by
having a nuclear stain
so you can use this technique to create
a cell body by proxy
and that can be convenient
so once you've identified um
sub-compartments like say the nucleus
and then the cell body
you can also go further and start
identifying other sub-compartments
within the cell as well
again with the proper fluorescent labels
you can identify
just about anything you want so here
this is using a i believe a
histone stain in order to identify dna
damage within the nuclei
and using all the same techniques that
i've just described
you can start identifying these
individual foci within nuclei
so you still have your pre-processing
step in which
you can see the foci in the upper left
image but with this high nuclear
background
you may have a hard time identifying the
individual foci so you can use some
background subtraction techniques to
remove the background fluorescence
within a nucleus
to get you something that looks more
like what's on the um
the upper right panel once you have this
pre-processed image
you can then do thresholding to identify
the individual foci
and then the one extra step that might
that can be needed
is to say you know there's still the
issue of which foci
belongs to which nucleus if you want to
do a say
per nucleus foci count and again
whatever software you're using
um should have some way to assign
relationships between
one set of objects versus another and so
the final step is saying
this foci within this region belongs to
say
this enclosing enclosing object
so coming back to our outline um now
assuming that you've
you've done your foreground
identification you've done your
thresholding you've done
your object identification
of whatever kind of objects
nucleus cell foci whatever else is
within the cell
that's of interest now you can start
going into actually
um making measurements
so the next several slides are actually
going to go into different types of
measurements that you can take and
really disguise the limit here
the most common type of measurement i
would say by far is just simply counts
of various types
so you have such measurements here as
the number of cells in an image or well
the number of organelles in a image or
well or the number of organelles per
cell
and just the simple number of objects or
number of cells per
image or well is often a useful readout
for qc purposes you can check
for say toxicity effects for example
uh measuring object morphology is
another very common
type of measurement and morphology this
is a word that can be used down in many
ways by different people but
essentially the definition is to reduce
some aspect of the object's shape to a
single value
and so when someone comes to me and says
i want to measure this the shape of my
cells
usually the next question i have is like
well what kind of shape measurement are
you looking at
here i just have a few types of features
that can be measured so
the area the perimeter of an object
those are kind of fairly straightforward
you know just simple geometry
eccentricity is the measure of object
how oblong or how oval like an
object is um major minor axis length
there's another
set of measurements that kind of measure
that same sort of thing uh form factor
can be a measure of compactness
then there is and then you're going kind
of down the line into some of the more
arcane features like say zerniky
features that
um measure essentially how pointy
an object is and this is just a subset
there are many more
types of object shape measurements that
can that can be done
um one thing that is um of note here is
that
if you have the option of if you're
interested in measuring shape
and you have the option of excluding
objects that touch the
border of the image you should probably
do so because um
taking shape shape measurements of say
half an object doesn't necessarily make
sense so if you exclude anything that
touches the border
you should do it
next measuring the object intensity is
another very common
type of readout that is obtained and
that's just simply
measuring making a measurement that's
proportional to the amount of
fluorescent label that's at a given
pixel location
and just like with morphology if you
were to say
you know i'm going to measure the
intensity there are a lot of different
types of intensity that can be measured
so some examples are the integrated or
total intensity so
the amount of the total amount of
fluorescence within a given object
across all the pixels
um which is assumed to be proportional
to the
um amount of of um your protein or
um what have you that's being labeled uh
the mean median standard deviation of
these intensities those themselves can
be
readouts upper lower intensity quartiles
you can also kind of combine these
together so correlations between
channels can you between multiple
fluorescent channels you can see how
the intensities vary with each other say
in one channel does the thrust go
up with a treatment um versus another
channel where
it goes down or do they both go up
together or go down together
um that's what correlation is begins to
begins to get at
or even co-localization do you see
multiple thrusted markers in the same
spatial location or not
um and as you can imagine since we're
dealing with intensity everything i've
said
before about the pre-processing in order
to do illumination correction applies so
you do want to make sure that
you illumination correct beforehand
before you start making sort of
intensity-based measurements
for texture texture is a little bit
harder to get a handle on
but in short it's a
measure of whether the staining
fluorescent staining pattern is either
smooth or coarse at a particular scale
and one way i'd like to look at it is if
i'm looking at say
you know the surface of a table if i'm
looking at it
say two feet away it may look very
smooth but if i'm looking at it
under an electron microscope it looks
like the surface of a moon
like lots of dips and hills and valleys
and so on
so it's the same object but depending on
the closeness or the scale that you're
looking at
the texture itself may be very very
different i think these uh
the images on the on the upper right
these are of um
virus capsules and you can see very
distinct textures
in each of these panels so higher scales
you'll get larger
patterns of texture smaller scales it
gets
finer patterns of texture and depending
on the biology those can be
described interesting phenotypes
here we have measuring location so
typically
the location of an cell within an image
is not terribly important whether it's
in the center or whether it's off to the
edge
you don't necessarily care but in some
cases
the location of an organelle within the
cell can be important and that's where
the xy location the proximity of
a organelle with respect to the nucleus
or respect to the
cell border those sort of location
measurements can be very important
and one one example of
such a measure of course would be time
lapse imaging usually
especially if the cells are moving so if
you're doing cell to cell tracking
in those cases you are very very
interested in exactly where the cell is
moving to and so the xy location within
an image becomes very important
and speaking of time lapse analysis
um just this quick uh diversion
uh here so you can imagine that this
sort of analysis is very very sensitive
um to all the constraints that i've
mentioned already
you really need to nail down object
identification
in order for time-lapse uh analysis to
work
if you're going to be connecting across
time
the location of an object from frame to
frame to frame
if an object drops out of view for any
one of the number of frames that just
makes your time-lapse analysis that much
harder
and it's just goes stands to reason
that garbage in garbage out gigo
applies here so before you even get to
the point of image analysis you really
want to make sure
that your asset development and your
acquisition those other components
of the um the um high content screening
toolkit are locked down before you even
get to this point
so but assuming you've done all that
then you definitely want to make sure
that you take note of any of the
segmentations
that may crop into your image by virtue
of whatever analysis you're doing
and of course there's a there's a number
of software tools both
commercial and open source that can help
you with these things
and here are measuring clustering so
spatial relationships between objects
how closely packed
a set of objects are those can
also be helpful measurements as well so
the number of neighbors an object has
the percentage of the perimeter that's
touching on
a neighboring object or the distance to
the nearest neighbor those can all be
readouts that are helpful
and you're not just limited just to
individual measurements you can also
combine them together so in some cases
identifying a phenotype of interest it
may be straightforward
if the phenotype is simple one or two
measurements that you can just sort of
pick out by hand
would be sufficient to pick out some
phenotypes
but for other phenotypes it's just a
much harder ask
and so this is where machine learning
can come in where machine learning
machine learning techniques
can take multiple uh measurements and
combine them together in order to define
your phenotype of interest
and it can do this not even not just
with the
sort of straightforward vanilla
measurements but even some of the ones
that are a bit more
um harder to to interpret like say
texture
for a human being can be hard to sort of
make sense of what some of these
measurements are but
with the machine learning approach you
know ill can do the right thing in terms
of
identifying your phenotypes of interest
and so heading into the last part of uh
of this presentation is this statistical
analysis portion
assuming that you've made all the
measurements that you've you need by
this point
so uh quality control is um is one key
idea
so of course any sort of quality control
should be done
at the beginning of the workflow so
a couple of typical quality control
measures that i
i tend to look for are focal issues
and also saturation artifacts so
the focal issues um this is just simply
um is your does your camera
go out of focus during the course of the
acquisition um due to exposure
um that's something that can often be
detected and or you know remedied if
found early enough
with saturation artifacts um i usually
see this in the form of
fluorescent of debris lint
or what have you that just made its way
into the well and ends up as a big
bright blob in the middle of your image
that in some cases ends up turning up as
a false positive when you're looking at
your hits
um if at all possible you can use
automated measures to define to find
each of these
and usually it's best to you know
spot check a number of these uh manually
just to make sure you don't miss
anything but also to make sure that your
qc metrics are doing what you're
what you're expecting and also there are
machine learning approaches here
you know not just for you know the sort
of thing can can be
used uh not just for identifying
phenotypes but if you
view a uh aberration as a phenotype unto
itself
machine learning can also be used for
exactly this in exactly the same ways as
i've described already
so assuming if qc the image then you can
start working
or digging into your data so what does
the data look like and so
in this case i'm going down to the
single cell level
in which um here is shown a single cell
and this
small uh thin line at the bottom is what
i'm calling a cytoprofile it's a
essentially a feature vector for which
each of the
measurements that you've taken this
identity is is part of this kind of
long barcode or string of numbers and
that's just for one cell
now imagine this for all the cells
across a well and for all the wells
across your experiment
and for all the features that you've
measured and you can easily
capture now not just one or two but tens
or hundreds or perhaps even thousands of
features and so you can imagine
that um the body of data that you're
working with is much much
is can be quite quite large gigabytes
perhaps terabytes of image
and this is just for a 2d image you can
imagine for a 3d
image or 3d plus time lapse where this
sort of thing can
um or you can deal with a lot of a lot
of data
very quickly so
given that one thing that's often done
with data analysis regardless of the
amount of data that you're dealing with
is data normalization
and this is used to remove any sort of
systemic
errors from the data so just by again by
virtue of the biology
you'll have you can run exactly the same
screen
in exactly the same conditions on one
day versus another
say day to day or month to month and
you'll see
differences that creep in through no
one's no fault
fault of anyone's own and data
normalization
provides a means to correct the data on
the
experiment to experiment level the idea
is that
similar measurements across different
wells with the same treatment
should be should correspond to each
other so this
points to the importance of having
controls
within your experiment again this is
going back to the essay development
phase
either positive controls naked controls
if you have both
great um common approaches to
do data normalization is say percentage
of control so you're taking each measure
and dividing
by the mean of that same measurement
from the control wells
if you don't have controls then you can
do a percentage of the examples
so you can take a measurement and divide
it by the mean of that measurement
from all the samples usually that
assumes that all the samples
are can be treated as basically similar
to negative controls
um it's not uncommon during screening
campaigns that most of your
library or um treatments do nothing
so you can treat those as if they were
negative controls
and then you can also do like z-scoring
robust z-scoring where you're taking
your data and transforming it such that
the mean is
set to zero and the variance is set to
set to um
set to one and that is another way to
normalize
and another way to do it is is to um
use percentiles rather than say standard
deviations that's a little bit more
robust outliers
in terms to statistical analysis
software um
again just like everything else there
are multiple ways to handle this
but spreadsheets are still kind of the
bread and butter
of this sort of field excel is still
very popular
in terms of just getting a first look at
the data that comes off
the data that comes out is usually in
some sort of table format
so spreadsheets are are
essentially ubiquitous um and everyone
knows about them
uh the problem here is that um for the
types of um
uh for large screens excel is going to
choke
if it um comes up with a if you handed a
csv that's more than a few
megabytes or gigabytes in size um
so again coming back to the microscope
fenders
sometimes not in all cases but many in
many cases they have some sort of
bundled software
that gives you some basic data analysis
functionality
and also some um that comes with the
image analysis tools
as well so
here's just again an example of some
statistical analysis
software and the caveat that this is not
comprehensive especially goes here
um because it's um these sort of tools
are not just for hcs but also for much
wider range of software as well
so you have a wide variety of products
they're often bundled with the software
and so as you
look at scopes or other hardware talk to
the vendor about details on this
open source tools include nine cell
profiler analysts
weka bioconductor and if you're more
into
doing programming then you can also work
up scripts
using matlab r and python
so um we're coming to the close circling
back
to the fundamental steps that i
described at the beginning
so starting with image acquisition i
took you through a little bit of what
pre-processing to clean up your images
in preparation for object detection
segmentation
and then once you have identified the
individual
objects within the within the image you
start making measurements
extracting features and once you have
those features there are different tools
you can use
to classify them interpret them and then
start making measurements and get your
final scientific results
out of it but at the end of the day all
of this is
is meaningless unless you as the
biologist or scientist are bringing your
knowledge about this particular
application or screen uh to the
forefront here
you will need to leverage the domain
knowledge that you have in order to make
the proper decisions at each point along
this workflow
so as far as additional resources are
concerned there's a lot out there but i
just wanted to point you to
just a couple in this area there is a
kind of an oldie but goodie this is from
2009 but it was put together by the
carpenter lab which gives you a nice
intro
um to two-dimensional fluorescence
analysis of microsp images from cla plus
uh computational biology there's a
review in nature methods from
2012 that goes over some of the
biological imaging uh
software tools and there's also the
essays guidance manual that was put
together by the nih which
covers not just image analysis but also
the
image essay development phase as well
so again the as part of the final
summary um
again we have these three components so
they all need to
work together be interlinked together
and be um
very thoughtfully considered all
together
but once you do you'll be prepared to
use image analysis to work on high
quality data and get some good science
out of it
so if that that is the end of
my talk and i'll be ready to take any
questions
and thank you dr gray for that
outstanding presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of the presentation as a
reminder please
submit your questions via the q a box
uh looks like we have a few questions
coming in already and
the first question is dr gray how can
you apply some of the correlations
when measuring objects in twin cities
okay yep um so i assume everyone can
hear me
but um yeah as far as these correlations
are concerned
so this is the sort of thing that
usually
whatever software you're using will have
it as an
added feature that can be um measured at
the same time
because the correlations are derived
from the intensities so of course you
need to
measure the intensities first and
depending on the software you have
it may just have it as an additional
option to get the correlations out of
out of them
um depending on how savvy you are in in
terms of um
sort of say programming or scripting or
that sort of thing if the software you
have does not
measure correlations for example um you
could say put it into
say fiji or imagej they have plug-ins
that allow for
measuring these sort of features or or
other features as well
so it's sort of a feature image feature
derived from a
image feature so there may be a little
bit more work that's involved if it's
not
already there as part of the package but
um
yeah it's certainly measurable with a
little bit of extra work
thank you so much great okay and the
next question we have is
as more people in aiml work on these
issues
where do you see the interpretations of
the biology becoming relevant
and who then will be interpreting
interpreting the data sets
joint or hand off to aiml
no okay so that is huge um
so ai just to make sure everyone's on
the same page so ai like artificial
intelligence
ml machine learning so those two things
usually go together
um but either way whatever you call it
aiml
is essentially letting the computer make
certain decisions
on um on sort of what the data
essentially
means so for example you know you
have a program or you feed in
a whole bunch of image features or
quantitative data
it goes through this you know sort of
black box
that's the machine learning program and
out on the other side
comes a decision like for example um
is this cell of phenotype a or phenotype
b
um that would be like a classification
problem
or it could be a situation where you
have um
you know data going in based on
controls like say positive controls
negative controls and then you have
more a regression problem where you feed
in
new data that has not seen before the ml
problem has not seen it
and then it makes the decision like is
it um
close to a or a or b or something in
between
um so it's not so much assigning a
a value to the input it's more
making a an assessment as
to um a predict essentially a prediction
of what this of um what the input
actually is
either way um the issue of
interpretation
is a big deal because like i said it's a
bit of a black box at times
um even for the people who make these
sort of programs um
a long-standing issue in the so-called
deep learning field it's that's a term
you may have
heard of before it's gotten a lot of
play and
from various companies like google
facebook all those sort of things
um you have um these
algorithms and machines that are making
these sort of decisions on biology
and you don't necessarily know or the
the biologist doesn't necessarily have a
window into
how the computer made that decision um
so the question comes up how do you know
it's right um
you can say manually check the answers
for say a few
screening treatments or a few
perturbations for a screen
but if you're dealing with like hundreds
and thousands or millions of
perturbations how do you know
um whether the answer is correct or
whether it even makes
you know any real sense and so
um you cannot cut the person completely
out of the picture
so at some point the biologist is still
there it's still the the onus of
responsibility still in the biologists
to confirm that what the
um ml you know box
is is coming up with actually holds
water um
is it completely one or the other do you
fully trust the machine or do you
doesn't have to be totally biologist
it's definitely going to be a joint
sort of a joint thing the two should be
working together
in some way and there is a
lot of ongoing research as to open up
the box
in other words to make the what the um
ml program's doing a little bit more
transparent so it's not so much of a
black box but
um getting it so the biologists can
understand what it's doing
and also um as time goes on
these sort of algorithms will become
more um
familiar and so the biologists may um
be more familiar with how these sort of
algorithms work and
develop more confidence in what is
coming out of them out of these
algorithms
so i can i see like these two pieces
kind of converging and moving towards
each other as as
as time goes on so that i think that's
that's basically my answer thank you so
much and
um those are all great questions we have
a couple more questions coming in
um the next one is do you think that
auto ml will take into account all
uh all these steps and that these types
of processes will be completed
automatically or will
or will it always be necessary an expert
to make the decisions
big decision yeah so it's
that's a kind of peering to the crystal
ball sort of uh sort of question
um so this very much kind of goes back
to the garbage in garbage out principle
and you've seen this not just in high
content screening space but in other in
other spaces where
um how well the ml works depends on the
input that it's trained on in order to
give your
to give the answer um the more
information it has
the better it will usually it usually
tends to do
so for certain assays or certain
conditions or um
circumstances there may come a point
where um
you can't sort of hand it off because
there's enough history there's enough
trap of a track record
to build with them between the um
what's being delivered by the box and
what's
um um the biologist who's interacting
with it
to say okay i can for this essay i can
pretty much
assume that it's going to give me the
the right answer and so there is that
handoff going on
um but for certain other cases um
the the biologist definitely needs to be
in there
definitely needs to be involved and
this is especially true as the stakes
get higher um
i'm not talking in this context we're
talking about probably early asset
development
but you can imagine for say clinical
trials you know uh cases where
patient outcomes are at stake um
you wouldn't necessarily the the um aiml
approach will definitely be helpful
but you would not necessarily want to
trust the entirety of patient outcomes
to um to just a machine you want uh
pathologists clinicians and so on still
in the picture so
i kind of i think that's an analogy that
i find helpful
um that um the the machines can
certainly be
human um human informed and will be
built up that way but a human is still
part of the picture
great thank you so much and then we have
um you
have as such database as as
concerns so what kind of cells
yeah yeah okay so
that is totally going to depend on the
essay um
the essay at stake so
for my purposes so for the work that i
tend to do this is all using microscopy
of
of course so the cells should be
amenable to imaging hopefully
they should be adherent so they actually
stick onto the surface
um in my particular case for this um
essay called cell painting which is
becoming more and more popular
um the cells should not only be adherent
but they hopefully should also be flat
they kind of look kind of like a fried
egg if you look at them from the side
that means when you take a microscope
and look at image planes through the
cell
you have a very um small focal depth and
you should be able to get
most of the cell with a single focal
plane and get much of the resolution
that you
that you need so cells that kind of fit
that bill
are are useful for that specific context
but even aside from imaging concerns
what it's going to be
what's going to drive it is physiologic
relevance what are the cells
that are the most relevant for what
you're studying
um in my case u2s cells are
good because they they're very image
ready in in that sense
um but you know they are a um you know
a bone cell line which you know may not
be relevant for say a different type of
cancer
um so you will definitely want to use
whatever cells are most relevant
and then but all the same tools tips
tricks you know those sort of things
segmentation measurement and so on
all still apply regardless of this of
the the cell line
um but at the end of the day it's going
to come down to
what's most relevant for your biology um
you know oh another one is also like you
know 2d or 3d
so um organoids are becoming more and
more of
a of a cell model that's being that's
being used so
you're going to need a whole set of
different concerns when it comes to 3d
imaging and 3d analysis you know are
your cells
amenable to that does that capture more
of the physiologic relevance well that
means you're going to have a whole new
set of challenges that come along with
it
and then cell lines versus primary cells
kind of those sort of issues again
you know primary cells are kind of
closest to human closest to patient
but they're notoriously can be difficult
to work with as compared to cell lines
so it's going to come down to usually
those sort of issues and this trade-off
between
you know how closes the cell cells to
the biology that you want to study
versus how easy are they to work with
and and you know
how imageable are they how well can you
get measurements and so on and so
there's not a one-size-fits-all answer
but hopefully you can find a compromise
that gets you where you want to be
these are all great questions thank you
so much for everyone being so engaging
and we have one we have time for one
final question
uh going back um what are
best practices as to designing an
experiment to analyze this way
numbers of plates numbers of replicates
uh objective
yeah yeah so this is kind of goes into
the initial assay development which
i'd mentioned is kind of the the stuff
you want to sort of nail down before you
even get to the analysis
side of things there's nothing worse
than having a whole set of
images show up on your desk and then you
realize oh the experiment just wasn't
quite designed the right way and then
you have to go back to the back to the
drawing board
so again this is going to be driven by
the biology that you're trying to study
so
i'll take them kind of in reverse order
so objective
the microscope objective itself um do
you want 10x
20x 60x um you essentially
want the objective that is going to
capture
um you know the detail that you want to
see
that describes the phenotype that you're
interested in um
so of course you could dial it all the
way up and go to like 60 or 100 actually
get like you know really high res images
but you're going to suffer from you know
if um you're going to take
more snapshots more fields of view
per well to capture everything that you
that you need so that's going to
increase your acquisition time
um is that a trade-off you're willing to
make um you know
more resolution for more imaging time
you might be able willing to do that or
it just may not be doable if you're
doing a screen of
you know a 50k compound screen
and the same thing goes for the other
categories or considerations as well so
number of replicates
ideally more replicates the better um
the more
you know technical or biological
replicates you have the better your
statistical power will be so that you
can trust the data that's coming out
but then you have to be willing to
accept the increased
acquisition time um culturing time
and so on to make those make those
replicates um
in in the cases i have looked at you
know typically like
three you know um um
the replicates would be would be
desirable per per treatment
um but there have been cases where we've
gone up to like you know five or six
but three seems to be pretty um pretty
common but again it's going to depend on
what you're looking at
and number plates usually will reflect
the number the number of replicates and
the number of treatments that you're
you're dealing with
um and again that's that's a logistical
concern you'll be
um are you doing a you know a screening
of 100
treatments or 100 compounds or is they
you know
50 000 uh compound screen
that's going to control the number of
plates and the number of replicates that
you can
you can um you can deal with so all of
these things kind of work
work together but it's going to be
driven by a combination of logistics
and the biology that you're trying to
capture and again finding a happy medium
that kind of gets you tries to get you
the best of all worlds
thank you again dr bray and thank you to
the audience for
these amazing questions um this is a
very informative presentation
uh it looks like we are running out of
time for today but as a final reminder
questions that were not were submitted
and not answered today by
our speaker while we address the email
and this presentation will be available
for
an on-demand viewing in the sb12 virtual
conference for 12 months
please remember to share it with
colleagues who might be interested in
today's topic and
don't forget to miss out on other
presentations on our agenda
thank you again for your participation
and until next time
have a great day thank you